let's jump into this first story from
the AP uh it's just so silly Alex Jones
ordered to pay 965 million dollars for
Sandy Hook lies an hour ago I I saw that
and I just burst it out laughing I think
it was on the toilet and I'm like I'm
looking at my phone and I'm like like
writing the news breaks I was like is
this a joke come on you know when they
did the 50 million dollars I was like
wow that's brutal they're still I still
doubt anyone's gonna get a penny from
this because the way lawsuits work Alex
Jones says he doesn't even have the
money anyway then they they're a billion
this is this is just like what is this
for narrative and for the TV to say oh
you know he lied about this and now he's
got to pay one billion dollars it
reminds me of uh Austin Powers when uh
in the first one he freezes himself and
then he goes to the Future and he says I
want one million dollars and they all
laugh at him and then they're like Dr
Evil one million dollars today isn't
actually a lot of money and he's like oh
and then in the next one he goes back in
time and says I want a hundred billion
dollars and I'll start laughing at me
again saying you might as well have just
said a bajillion gajillion dollars that
money doesn't exist this is what it is
like who and and who in their right mind
thinks Alex Jones has a billion dollars
to give away I don't think anyone I
don't and I I mean I mean he's been
pretty transparent with his finances and
he doesn't I don't understand there's a
phrase squeezing trying to squeeze blood
from a stone from a turnip from a turnip
yeah uh I I don't know how the law Works
in this kind of situation where
someone's gets sued for money that they
don't have I'm sorry I'm sorry this is
the biggest judgment in U.S history
apparently for defamation and it's
people want a judgment for defamation
that weren't even named by Alex Jones I
don't understand this there were like
six people six people's families and an
FBI agent that was involved somehow is
pain and suffer bring from something
else I mean I understand he named
someone and then that person has phone
calls people went to that person's house
I think I don't know what the extent of
the what happened that I get that guy
can sue for defamation he got named for
something that but the rest of them I
don't I don't understand this and it's
setting a precedent there wasn't even a
trial they just had a judgment because
they had problems with uh Discovery and
uh this is the second of a of three
trials there's still going to be yet
another trial and this settlement you
know this this judgment excuse me is
almost as big as of course one of the
biggest Health Care fraud settlements in
history which was given to Pfizer that
had to pay 2.3 billion dollars for
fraudulent marketing back a couple years
ago so uh when you compare the two uh
you know bad opinions compared to what
Pfizer did back then there's a big
difference well here's a question then
so so what should what should happen and
I don't have an answer to this let's say
you're a parent of the Sandy Hook thing
uh you're devastated now people turning
up your house because of what Alex Jones
said what should happen maybe nothing
well I mean it's tough uh for one Alex
had said that under Texas law you have
to say someone's name for it to be
defamation and that he was just saying
these people and those people but I
think he did name one person there was
one individual he named uh I'll say this
Alex Jones went on a show to a massive
audience and said things that were not
true he's allowed to have his opinions
but when he said things definitively
there's a question there of defamation
when you when you call out someone with
false information it was not a public
figure I don't think the New York Times
should be allowed to get away with it my
big issue my my there's there's a couple
of things I I have issue with here one a
billion dollars is just the stupidest
thing I've ever heard
uh they didn't give him a trial and when
it when are any of these big major media
organizations ever going to be held to
account in any in any in any way let
alone anyway like this it's not
happening so you can see how the machine
comes for people who are outside of the
establishment I would say I would find
it reasonable if Alex Jones was actually
ordered to pay you know six figures to
each family for each family member
something like that maybe the total
payout would have been like five million
bucks and they would have said that to
cover the cost of security and moving
all the legitimate you know um all the
legitimate costs incurred by these
families but the idea is here punitive
damages the the judges act I'm sorry the
lawyers actually said to the jury find
him so much he cannot
keep his business up or up and running
or something something to that effect so
the goal here is to punish him so that
he doesn't do it again and I just think
that is where I say no that's wrong and
I'll tell you Alex Jones is allowed to
be wrong about things he's allowed to
have his opinion about things now if he
defamed by saying statements of fact
that we're not true about private
individuals then I think he owes them
damages but if it was that he truly
believed it and he was expressing his
opinion on a major news event then I
don't see how you come after him for
tens of millions or even a billion
dollars paying for actual damages
because you you were wrong and spread
misinformation about someone that
damaged their life that I understand
I'm thinking about a metaphor I know
you'll love it uh about like social
media Administration and one of the
things that Minds that we talk about is
if you ban someone for violating terms
of service you ban the channel and then
when they try and make a new channel
some of the admins would be like no they
can't make any more channels they
violated the terms I'm like no no you're
not Banning the person you're Banning
the channel the channel violated the
terms so it's the same thing with Alex
you you you you don't stop him from
coming back that's not the point you
punish him for the for the fraud or
whatever or the the problem but there's
no like preventing people from existing
or a realm back to you know normality I
that's my opinion anyway or Redemption
you know it's essential right the human
the conversation is about Redemption
we're all I mean that's the Christian
ethos these people aren't Christians
well our society ship is kind of based
on it and and that's I think that's a
good thing
um I think uh progress is a good thing
but I think there's there's a lot of
values that come from
uh
Christian values that I think are good
notably like innocent until proven
guilty is a really good one and there's
a lot of bad ones and and we found over
the over a long period of time we've
gotten rid of the bad ones but I think
with with this the issue comes down to
you cannot get rid of Alex Jones it's
impossible okay here you go
um John Smith starts a media company and
then says Alex I'm gonna hire you and
I'm going to pay you ten dollars an hour
to host you know this show a benefit of
working for this company is that you're
going to eat at a five-star restaurant
steakhouse every night the company pays
for your Penthouse and you get a car a
corporate car and you get corporate
private jets but you only get paid 10
bucks an hour what are they gonna do rad
that's cool what are they gonna do so if
Alex Jones has a personality on a show
generates millions of dollars tens of
millions hundreds of millions so if they
sue him into Oblivion he has a trusted
individual who has a company and hires
them and then what now if at that point
he says something again they can sue
that company sure but then what just do
it again it's it's ridiculous you cannot
there's nothing you can do to stop Alex
Jones He is Unstoppable he is he is a
gigantic man Boulder rolling down a hill
you will not stop him
I want you to imagine Alex Jones rolling
down a hill at 100 miles an hour just he
hits the bottom of that ramp and then he
just goes flying through the air and
then Supernova yeah and he's like
meditating in the sky as he's flying
like that Pokemon not Pikachu I forgot
who it is but but let me let me say this
how many times I'll put it this way the
New York Times the lies about the Iraq
War and all of that stuff that the the
lies about Iraq that got us into a war
that cost what how many people died yeah
really how many how many innocent
civilians were killed how much money was
wasted how much damage just around the
world because of this
have we sued the New York Times into
Oblivion to make sure they can never
operate again
no of course not they just say well you
know don't do it again
and we all suffer because of it Alex
Jones says incorrect things about a
bunch of families that I I think he was
it was wrong of him to say and in the
end they're like let's make sure he can
never ever run a company they want to
destroy not just his life they want to
destroy the lives of anyone who worked
for him even a guy who's like a
groundskeeper or security guard that's
insane I'm gonna tell you one more very
very important thing especially as it
pertains to censorship
when they censored Alex Jones on YouTube
this isn't very important they did not
just take away his ability to speak they
deleted the entire Archive of all of the
work he had ever produced and published
on that platform that's the scary thing
about social media censorship it doesn't
just say you can't talk anymore Twitter
Facebook YouTube erases your entire
history gone and then you can't comply
with Discovery and then they're like
where's the video clips where's the
video footage where's your apology when
when did you say sorry show us the
details and of course no one has the
ability to have that many hard drives
that that many backups of how I mean he
streams essentially what is it four
hours a day on his show and then there's
a bunch of other shows that he goes on
so it's just impossible and and truly
the larger censorship efforts are
repundant and disgusting and the
corporate media does what Alex Jones
does every single day the only
difference is they never get held
accountable for all the lies and all the
disinformation that they spew repundant
yeah that's a that's a word right
repugnant I love that potato potato you
know what I'm saying I thought it was a
word I didn't know but there you go yeah
it sounded quite good to me but the
context transfer people got people got
it is the issue is the issue that I mean
this was an emotional reaction I suppose
it's like a billion dollars or whatever
it is I I do agree with what you're
saying uh actually now that I think
about this to delete someone's entire
Archive of work seems insane but I also
just feel like what is to stop all of us
now from just saying whatever we want
that completely ruins someone's life
that might not be true what should be
human decency I guess uh morals ethics
um to an extent the Christian values
that uh were instilled in this country
whether you like them or don't they're
there
uh what should be done is defamation
towards civil tort you you know I think
we have a problem with times V Sullivan
are you familiar with times V Sullivan
this is a precedent that basically says
politicians and public Figures it's not
just times of Sullivan there's another
court case that added to it but it's
basically the precedent that says
if you're a public figure then there's a
higher degree of scrutiny and I think
that you know there's there's good
things and bad things about it but I
think it kind of weighs on the negative
what this means is
if CNN comes out and lies about me and
says that you know Tim Poole you know
punched a dog and then I sue and say no
I didn't they'll say you're a public
figure
oh well that's no good no and so I mean
saying that I punched a dog is a very
definitive thing it's it so they they
probably would have a hard time with
saying something that definitive but
they can come out and say that you're a
known white supremacist who sympathizes
and and does this that or otherwise and
then if you try and Sue they'll say it's
a protected opinion against a public uh
you know public uh person and so it you
case dismissed if you're a private
individual then you've got way more
grounds which is why Alex Jones
basically lost here but I think the real
reason he lost here is because the
machine was out to get him that's my
opinion on the matter I mean it's pretty
clear I mean look what the corporate
media does just a few months ago uh
during the whole Afghanistan debacle the
United States Pentagon military
literally launched a missile strike and
killed a native worker the U.S corporate
media said that he was Isis K that he
was a terrorist he was an aid worker
that was bringing fresh water to
Afghanistan that's liable that's
defamation this family is being defamed
as some kind of new radical islamist
Terror wrists when in reality they were
working with the US government bringing
fresh water to Afghanistan is the
corporate media going to be held
responsible for that particular incident
of defamation of lying about someone
that just had their entire family
annihilated in a in a drone strike that
the corporate media and the U.S pentagon
were lying about no should they if we're
going to be playing by these rules
absolutely and I think you would get a
reward more than a billion dollars for
such defamations and such actions if
we're playing by the same rules set by
the president of this particular court
uh hearing I don't normally do super
chats this early but there is one that I
want to address because I brought it up
and I think for people who are listening
to the segment they should hear it
Augusto mimichay says where is innocent
until proven guilty in the Bible he who
is without sin isn't the same no it is
the story of Sodom and Gomorrah and it
was I think it was Abraham was talking
to God and God was like you know I'm
probably getting the story wrong with
the general ideas you know I'm gonna
blow up these cities because they're
full of you know nasty people and then
he he asks but what if there are 50
right righteous people and he's like
okay if there are 50 righteous people I
won't blow it up I said what about 40.
okay if there's 40 and then finally
comes down to what if there's but one
righteous man and he says okay if
there's one righteous man I will not
destroy these cities the idea there is
that you cannot condemn someone to death
if they are a righteous person right
that's a general idea that was the
inspiration for blackstone's formulation
it is better that 10 guilty persons
Escape than one innocent person suffer
which then went to Benjamin Franklin who
said is better than a hundred guilty
persons Escape than one innocent person
suffer and the philosophy there the
legal and moral and governmental
philosophy is if people don't have faith
that has innocent individuals they will
be protected from false accusations if
people believe that even if they are
innocent the machine will try to crush
them then they don't lend their
confidence to government government
doesn't work ultimately this becomes the
element of the government that is you
must have a trial you must be proven
guilty you can confront your accusers
and you are innocent until they prove
you're guilty it's amazing I I was
reading about you know why I was reading
about the Constitution where these ideas
came from why we had them and I traced
that one all the way back it was very
very fascinating so uh yeah there we go
they say that 10 of people in prison are
innocent and it reminds me of Amanda
Knox remember Amanda oh yeah yeah she
was on my my podcast and she's this
lovely person she seems so nice and the
minute I put that out the amount of
abuse I got and that she got she now has
to live with that because people don't
go by innocent until proven guilty
they're just all convinced she did it
you know yeah the court of public
opinion now yeah yeah and that's the
problem with stuff like uh this Alex
Jones thing most people uh don't even
know the full details of the of the
trial and I'm not going to pretend to
either I think if you if you watch
someone like Viva Frye you might get a
much much better understanding of how
the court case played out and everything
like that but then you take a look at
like the Ahmed Aubry case you take a
look at the Kyle Rittenhouse case there
are Mobs with pitchforks going around
demanding violent ends to to you know
and and they don't even know what
happened like hands up don't shoot
people were riding over the Michael
Brown stuff they're trying to be fake
Ferguson was the West Florissant in
Ferguson was burnt to the ground all
these buildings over lies lies from the
media and the media went there and they
were all gloating and talking about I
was a great networking event these
people are nasty people man
so I don't think this is uh this is
going to be a devastating blow against
Alex Jones because he is very persistent
and I think he's definitely going to
figure out a lot of different ways
around this I think he already has
safeguarded a lot of his assets and a
lot of his uh a lot of his businesses
but but also more importantly a lot of
legal experts are saying that he's going
to win on appeal when it comes to of
course challenging this major decision
there are still again one more court
hearing that's going to of course be
going after him but more importantly I
think with hyperinflation the one
billion dollars is going to be a
cakewalk especially with the value of
the dollar going down with the Federal
Reserve Quantic quantitative easing
policies that have utterly destroyed our
currency and a billion dollars is going
to be nothing in a few in a few months
from now thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there